A FORMER KGB SPY, ANGRY AT
CANNOT LAPS OF HIS MOTHERLAND
PLOTS A COURSE FOR REVENGE.
IMAGINE THAT MOVIE.
>> Tucker: ROB REINER HAS SPENT
MONTHS SOUNDING IT A LARM ABOUT
RUSSIA.
LAST FALL HE HELPED MAKE A VIDEO
AND HE'S VERY EXCITED ABOUT
TODAY'S INDICTMENTS.
TODAY HE TWEETED THIS, QUOTE,
IT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT RUSSIA
HAD A PROFOUND EFFECT ON THE
2016 ELECTION, CONTINUING TO
ATTACK US.
TRUMP ISN'T WILLING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT OR PROTECT US.
THE WORD TREE SON IS NOW CENTER
STAGE.
FREE SON.
ROBIN -- TREE SON.
ROB, HOW ARE YOU.
>> GOOD TODAY YOU.
>> Tucker: I WOULD THINK AFTER
LEADING THE SERIES OF
INDICTMENTS THAT SAY THE
RUSSIANS SUPPORTED TRUMP,
ATTACKED HILLARY, SUPPORTED
BLACK LIVES MATTER AND BERNIE,
THE RUSSIANS ALSO HAD AN
ANTI-TRUMP RALLY IN FRONT OF
TRUMP TOWER, YOU WOULD BE A
LITTLE EMBARRASSED BY TWEETS
LIKE THIS AND YOUR HYSTERIA
GENERALLY.
ARE YOU?
>> NO.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, TUCKER.
EVERYBODY OUT THERE KNOWS THAT
YOU AND I ARE ON OPPOSITE SIDES
OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
I MEAN THAT'S -- WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
SO WHAT I'M THINKING RIGHT NOW
IS YOU AND I, TOGETHER, BECAUSE
WE'RE SO FAR APART POLITICALLY,
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE, TO
DO A GREAT SERVICE TO THE
COUNTRY.
IF ALL WE HAVE TO DO, AND THIS
IS NOT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S COLLUSION, OR WHETHER OR
NOT WHATEVER THE RUSSIANS DID
DEFINITELY OR DIDN'T AFFECT THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
ALL YOU AND I HAVE TO DO AT THIS
POINT IS AGREE WITH WHAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN SAID TODAY.
DO YOU GROW WITH THAT OR NO?
>> Tucker: I GUESS.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW.
YEAH, I DON'T LIKE FOREIGN
COUNTRIES MEDDLING IN OUR
AFFAIRS.
I DON'T THAT YOU TAILOR YOUR
MOVIES TO THE CHAMPIONESE
SENSORS SPECIFICATIONTION AS YOU
THE CHINESE SPECIFICATIONS.
I DON'T LIKE FOREIGN SWER
FEERNS, I FIND IT OFFENSIVE.
WHEN YOU ACCUSE SOMEBODY OF
TREASON, UNPATRIOTIC, YOU USE
PHRASES LIKE THAT.
WHY DO THAT?
>> NO, NO, I DIDN'T I CUES HIM
OF TREASON.
>> Tucker: YES YOU DID.
>> WHAT I SAID WAS IF HE IS
REFUSING TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT THE RUSSIANS DID ATTACK US
DURING THE ELECTION, AND IF HE
REFUSES TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT,
THEN YOU'RE CONSPIREING WITH AN
ENEMY.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
>> Tucker: CAN I ASK YOU, ARE
YOU AWARE THAT -- OKAY.
YOU WANT SOMEBODY TO DO -- BUT
WE'RE KILLING RUSSIANS IN SYRIA,
TRUMP KILLED A BUNCH MUCH OF
THEM.
WERE YOU EXCITED HE KILLED
RUSSIANS?
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT --
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS IN SYRIA OR WHAT
HAPPENED IN SYRIA.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
>> Tucker: WERE YOU EXCITED HE
KILLED RUSSIANS IN SYRIA, WHAT
DID YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I DON'T HAVE AN OPINION ABOUT
THAT.
I KNOW ALL I KNOW IS --
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> NO, I DON'T.
ALL I KNOW IS WHAT HAPPENED,
WE'VE BEEN INVADED AND THEY
CONTINUE TO DO, TO TROY AND
DISRUPT OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND LIKE YOU JUST POINTED OUT,
EARLY, YOU KNOW THEY'LL GO ON
BOTH SIDES.
THEY'LL TRY TO HELP BERNIE, JILL
STEIN, ANYTHING TO DISRUPT
DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THE
RUSSIANS HAVE MORE INFLUENCE IN
OUR COUNTRY THAN THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT TO WHICH YOU
ROUTINELY KOWTO FWHCHLT YOUR
FILMS?
LOOK INTO THE CAMERA, DO THE
RUSSIANS HAVE MORE EFFECT, MORE
EFFECT ON AMERICAN SOCIETY THAN
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
WHY DID YOU SAY THAT I KOWTOW TO
THEM IN MY FILMS?
>> Tucker: HOLLYWOOD FILMS, AS
YOU KNOW, WOULD NEVER HAVE A
FLATTERING PORTRAYAL OF THE
DALAI LAMA, CHINESE DOESN'T WANT
IT.
AMERICAN FILL RMS SENSORED, GO
ALONG WITH THE IMPERATIVES OF
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT SENSORS.
YOU KNOW, THIS YOU LIVE THERE.
>> I DON'T, NO, I DON'T --
YOU'RE SAYING THAT I SENSOR
MYSELF FOR THE CHINESE.
I DON'T DO THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE HAPPENS
FROM EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> Tucker: UM-HUM.
BUT YOU DO KNOW.
>> I DON'T.
HERE'S THE THING, TUCKER, IF YOU
AND I CAN AGREE, ALL WE HAVE TO
DO IS AGREE THAT THE RUSSIANS
TRIED TO MEDDLE AND DISRUPT OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE TO AGREE ON.
>> Tucker: NO, LOOK, I THOUGHT
THIS FOR YEARS --
>> YOU DIDN'T LET ME FINISH.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT THE ROSEN
BERGS WERE GUILTY.
I'M SERIOUS.
I THINK THE RUSSIANS HAVE DONE
IT FOR YEARS.
MANY COUNTRY DOES IT.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THEY DO IT.
THEY DO DO IT.
AND THE RUSSIANS EVERY BEEN
DOING IT FOR YEARS.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE, CALL ACTIVE MELS
URS AND DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS, THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING
FOR YEARS AND NOW IS THAT, IT'S
ON STEROIDS BECAUSE OF THE
INTERNET.
AND BECAUSE OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
SO IT'S MUCH MORE POWERFUL
EFFECT OF WHAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH.
>> Tucker: DO YOU AGREE YOU
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T CALL PEOPLE
UNPATRIOTIC OR TREASONOUS ON
YOUR TWITTER ACCOUNT?
>> I WOULDN'T SAY THEY'RE
UNPATRIOTIC OR TREES TREASONESS
UNLESS THEY WOULDN'T PROTECT US
AGAINST FOREIGN POWERS.
MAYBE HE WILL.